je t'ai entendu faire l'idiote devant ma
porte chanter à quelle heure est ce que
cette clé ferme la porte
tu veut traîner dehors avec ses vrilles
york et vas-y mais après devient pas
frapper à ma [ __ ] de porte
[Musique]
est ce que tu sais quel âge et elle n'a
que seize vous voulez pas que votre vie
soit heureuse vous voulez qu'elle reste
malheureuse que vous montez un connard
de fitte trêve je ne sais où j'essaie de
jouer les adultes et voilà de retour
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec méchante
[Musique]
je sais que la rue vous attire mais vous
devez trouver une autre issue et
résister à cet appel
là pas besoin de chauny tuer ce qu'il
faut et pas allez c'est parti
[Musique]